bonsoir
alors quand j'étais enfant je me posais
beaucoup de questions je me demandais
comment fonctionnaient les marais
comment les avions faisait pour voler et
j'adorais l'émission c'est pas sorcier
alors je pense que vous aussi vous avez
dû grandir avec cette émission
c'était passionnant c'était très bien
expliquer vulgariser et cette émission
permettait de répondre à beaucoup de
questions que je me posais ensuite après
cette émission j'aimais regarder turbo
oui c'est très différent
cette émission nous intéresser puisque
on voyait de belles voitures mais aussi
parce qu on y découvrait différentes
nouvelles technologies et des choses qui
paraissaient des gadgets pour moi à
l'époque
alors aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de
pouvoir allier science et automobiles
puisque mon travail consiste à chercher
de nouveaux éléments pour les moteurs
électriques des voitures alors je parle
de la voiture en général mais surtout de
la voiture électrique et je vais
commencer par vous poser une question
qui pense que la voiture électrique ne
pollue pas du tout donc je pense que
c'est unanime et qui pense que la
voiture électrique pollue
ah oui d'accord donc vous avez à peu
près compris la voiture électrique
certes elle a été créée pour répondre à
une problématique environnementale
l'idée c'est de réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et donc de ralentir
le réchauffement climatique alors la
voiture électrique c'est ça mais c'est
aussi ce type de choses ce que vous
voyez ici c'est la plus grande mine de
terres rares présentes en chine
il s'agit de la mine de baotou elle se
trouve en mongolie intérieure est en
fait les terreur ce sont des éléments
chimiques métalliques pour lesquels
l'extraction et la séparation produisent
des déchets chimiques et radioactifs
donc ces éléments sont hautement
polluants donc contrairement à leur nom
c'était rare ne sont pas toutes rare
elle existe en différentes proportions
sur tout le globe terrestre de manière
non homogène
alors si je vous parle de terres rares
aujourd'hui c'est parce que ces terres
rares sont présents dans les aimants des
moteurs électriques de voitures et pas
seulement la voiture électrique
dans votre propre voiture que vous avez
vous il y a beaucoup de moteur qui
fonctionne avec des aimants permanents
qui sont des moteurs électriques par
exemple pour ouvrir votre vitre ou pour
actionner les essuie glaces avant
arrière et cetera il n'y a plus de 20
moteurs à aimants permanents
si l'on s'intéresse aussi aux moteurs de
traction de la voiture celui qui va la
faire avancer
il peut y avoir aussi des aimants et
s'il y en a ce sont des éléments qui
vont des terres rares donc ils sont
polluants alors les terres rares les
voici dans le tableau périodique des
éléments
vous vous souvenez c'est le tableau que
vous avez sûrement découvert au collège
ou au lycée et qui classe les éléments
selon le nombre d'électrons leur poids
et qui donne énormément d'informations
l'intérêt de celui-ci il est particulier
c'est que vous avez également les prix
des éléments vous pouvez voir en
référence tout en bas sur votre droite
qu'il ya différents prix et qui sont en
dollars par kilogramme vous remarqué
assez rapidement je pense au centre un
amas d'atomes qui sont en noir qui sont
très chers
il s'agit de des métaux tels l'or et le
platine par exemple ça tout le monde
sait que c'est très cher ensuite
donc si on isole les terreur ce sont ces
éléments là il s'agit de la grande barre
en bas qui sont les quinze lanthanides
et il ya également l'yttrium le scandium
qui sont sur le côté vous pouvez
remarquer que ces éléments sont chers
mais il y en a en particulier qui
servent pour les aimants il s'agit de
ces trois là donc le néodyme le samarium
et le dysprosium donc en plus d'être
polluants ces éléments coûte cher
donc il faut s'en passer et moi les
éléments que j'utilise ce sont ceux-là
donc vous remarqué que globalement ils
sont peu chères ce sont non plus des
éléments qui ne sont pas polluants et
vous allez me dire oui mais le baryum
lui il est en rose donc ça veut dire
qu'ils coûtent un peu mais j'en utilise
suffisamment peu pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'impact sur le prix de mes éléments
alors je fabrique des aimants mais il
faut avoir un petit peu d'histoire
à l'origine il faut savoir que l'aimant
il n'est pas naturellement aimanté et
ceux qui étaient découverts par les
hommes et avait été éventée par le champ
magnétique terrestre
ensuite l'homme s'est mis à fabriquer
des éléments et il était composé d'acier
vous pourriez remarquer qu' il était
sous forme de fer à cheval
vous avez souvent
but dans des dessins animés quand vous
étiez enfant les personnages qui se
retrouvaient accroché avec un aimant en
forme de fer à cheval qui était très
puissant il pouvait pas en sortir mais
finalement pourquoi cette forme
pourquoi un fer à cheval donc comme je
vous disais il faut augmenter le
matériau donc pour les mentent et nous
appliquons un champ magnétique et
lorsque le léman va se polariser c'est à
dire qu'il va se créer un pôle nord et
un pôle sud
il va y avoir un champ interne qui
s'appelle champ des magnétisant qui va à
l'envers c'est à dire qu'il va déserter
le matériau donc le matériau léman peut
se démente et tout seul sans son propre
champ à très pratique
donc pour éviter ça avec les aciers il
avait été remarqué qu'on leur donne à
cette forme de fer à cheval
il était possible d'éviter la
déshydratation au centre en éloignant au
maximum le matériau et que l'on obtenait
un très bon et man en concentrant le
champ au niveau des pôles donc il
fallait les rapprocher depuis il existe
des mandé aimant qui sont composées de
différentes de différent at home et il
n'est plus nécessaire de les faire sous
forme de fer à cheval
donc il existe des éléments très
performant tout petit et sous forme de
pastilles ça peut vous servir par
exemple pour fermer une housse de
téléphone
les derniers qui ont été découverts
contiennent eux des terres rares
malheureusement ce sont les plus
énergétiques existent sur le marché et
donc je cherche à faire de nouveaux
éléments qui ne contiennent pas de
terres rares et j'ai commencé par
essayer d'améliorer l'effet rites que
vous voyez ici alors les ferrite ce sont
des éléments qui sont composés de fer
d'oxygène et un petit peu de baryum et
de strontium ce sont des éléments qui
existe déjà sur le marché puisque c'est
ce qui vous permet d'ouvrir votre vitre
de voiture et c'est également les
éléments que vous ramenez de vos
vacances et vous coller ensuite sur
votre réfrigérateur
alors pour améliorer ces matériaux je
passe par la voie de la
nanostructuration c'est à dire que je
synthétise une poudre aux tailles de
grains nanométrique que je vais orienté
alors je m'explique pour fabriquer un
aimant il faut d'abord synthétiser une
poudre on va considérer que chaque grain
est un aimant avec son pôle nord et son
pôle sud et en appliquant un autre champ
magnétique tous les grains vont
s'orienter selon un seul et même axe
nord-sud
alors finalement pourquoi utiliser des
grains aussi petit
si j'utilise une poudre avec des gros
grain il peut y avoir deux orientations
ensuite différentes ou plus d'ailleurs
au sein du même grain c'est ce qu'on
appelle des domaines ces domaines sont
séparés par une paroi et si j'applique
un champ magnétique vers le haut la
paroisse va se décaler vers la droite et
j'obtiens un seul domaine ont jusque là
rien de très compliqué par contre si
j'utilise des grains tout petit il ne
peut pas se créer deux parois donc il va
y avoir qu'un seul domaine ces grains on
l'est on dit qu'ils sont mono domaine si
j'applique à nouveau un champ magnétique
vers le haut le grain va tout simplement
tourné pour s'orienter selon ce champ
que j'applique dans cette même direction
alors pourquoi faire ça l'utilité
d'avoir des grès un tout petit c'est que
nous avons ainsi un moyen d'augmenter la
résistance à la déréglementation sous un
champ magnétique à nouveau le fer à
cheval comme nous l'augmentons il n'est
plus nécessaire d'avoir un aimant sous
forme de fer à cheval
alors le problème avec ces petits grains
c'est que les forces magnétiques sont
très fortes que c'est grave on crée des
agglomérats qu'il faut donc casser les
agglomérations pouvoir orienter et avoir
tous les grains selon un seul et même
axe donc c'est encore aujourd'hui un
gros problème sur les nanopoudres et
mais nous travaillons à de nouvelles
solutions pour orienter ce matériau
ensuite je m'intéresse à un autre type
de matériau il est composé de manganèse
et d'aluminium c'est un matériau qui
peut présenter des propriétés
magnétiques très élevé et il a été
découvert dans les années 50 il n'a pas
encore été industrialisée puisque
jusqu'à présent les propriétés
magnétiques n'était pas suffisante face
à ce qui existait déjà sur le marché
mais il est nouvelles technologies nous
permettent aujourd'hui de lui rendre ses
propriétés bonnes propriétés et
l'intérêt particulier de ce matériau
c'est qu'il est léger il est peu cher il
est facile à recycler puisque les
aimants qui contiennent des terreur eux
on ne peut pas les recycler encore
aujourd'hui donc l'aluminium on sait
qu'il est recyclé depuis très longtemps
le manganèse il extrait en même temps
que le faire et ce sont des éléments qui
sont considérés comme non polluants
donc je vais synthétiser je fais faire
des alliages de manganèse et d'aluminium
alors tout à l'heure je faisais des
procédés chimiques donc avec une blouse
une hotte avec des gants et des lunettes
à présent cd procédé de métallurgie et
pour tout vous dire avant pour moi la
métallurgie et quelque chose comme ça
j'imaginais qu'on allait me demander de
porter un tablier en cuir et comme
représenté ici que donc il fallait
chauffer le métal de l'épée tremper dans
de l'eau etc
c'est effectivement de la métallurgie
mais moi j'utilise plutôt des machines
qui ressemble à ça donc ce que vous ce
que vous voyez c'est un moyen de faire
fondre par induction mais métaux
l'induction finalement c'est exactement
ce qui se passe dans les plats que vous
avez chez vous vous voyez qu'il ya une
bobine un courant électrique va passer
dans la bobine et il va se créer un
champ magnétique en hausse entre le
champ magnétique va interférer avec le
moule et de cette manière je vais
pouvoir faire fondre très rapidement
mais métaux c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
vous faut des plaques spéciales
enfin des poils spéciale pour vos
plaques et que donc du coup les aliments
vont chauffer beaucoup plus vite ensuite
j'obtiens donc mon alliage et je vais le
passer dans la grosse qualité que vous
voyez à droite
à l'intérieur de cette qualité il y à
une rouge refroidi qui tourne très très
vite
à nouveau je vais faire fondre mon
matériau par induction et je vais
l'éjecter très rapidement sur cette roue
qui tourne
de cette manière j'obtiens alors des
rubans ces rubans ce ne sont toujours
pas un aimant il va falloir encore
procédé faire beaucoup de choses sur ces
sur ces rubans et je commence par les
broyer à différentes températures à
différentes vitesses ensuite je vais
devoir les comprimés et c'est finalement
c'est un peu de la cuisine mais c'est
aussi un peu comme faire des macarons je
ne sais pas si vous avez déjà essayé
d'en faire c'est finalement pas si
simple il faut procéder par étapes il
faut bien respecter la recette sinon ça
ne fonctionne pas on n'a pas le beau
dôme brillant la collerette et le
moelleux des macarons donc moi c'est un
peu pareil si je chauffe trop si je bois
trop mon matériau se décompose en des
phases qui ne sont pas magnétique et du
coup je ne peux pas fabriqué mon élément
donc j'ai une certaine phase qui sort de
mes 2 2 mais ruban mais qui n'est
toujours pas mon élément
il se présente sous cette forme que vous
voyez à gauche c'est à dire que j'ai une
phase qui est un hexagone très allongée
mois celle qui m'a
ray c'est plutôt le cube très
sympathique qui est à droite donc du
coup pour l'obtenir
nous avons décidé d'appuyer très très
fort finalement sur nos hexagonales ont
j'ai tout en chauffant assez pour
effectuer la transformation d'une phase
à l'autre et de cette manière nous
espérons qu'il va se crée également une
phase un pôle nord est un peu le sud
alors l'organisation des atomes a permis
d'obtenir ces cultures est aplatie et
les résultats sont mitigés puisque nous
avons nous n'avons toujours pas ce pôle
nord et ce pôle sud mais nous avons
réussi à augmenter de 40% la
désorientation par un champ extérieur ou
par son propre champ de ce matériau ce
qui n'était pas gagné au départ nous
avons aussi à nous à présent un paiement
qui pourrait peut-être assez rapidement
trouvé sa place dans le moteur de
traction de la voiture électrique
donc du coup nous avons proposé ici des
solutions pour essayer de remplacer ces
éléments qui sont hautement polluants
met donc au départ je vous parlais
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
parce que vous imaginez maintenant que
la voiture est effectivement c'est très
polluant mais bon il faut quand même
dire que la voiture électrique ça permet
malgré tout de réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre comme vous pouvez
le voir ici lors de la phase
d'utilisation il n'y a presque pas
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
comparés à un véhicule qui fonctionnent
au diesel ou à l'essence
à condition bien sûr d'utiliser des
énergies renouvelables donc c'est au
niveau de la fabrication et de la fin de
vie du véhicule où il ya encore
aujourd'hui un souci est donc il faut
travailler là dessus
et puis finalement ce qui nous intéresse
nous c'est que la voiture électrique a
soit attractif fond nous automobilistes
et pour cela il faut que la voiture soit
la puissante il faut qu'elles aient une
bonne autonomie puisque la voiture
électrique
on a encore aujourd'hui pas la meilleure
autonomie ce n'est pas ce qu'on attend
et puis il faut aussi en diminuer le
coût parce que les voitures électriques
coûtent encore trop cher et noé mans
pourrait contribuer à une petite hauteur
sur ces trois plans puisque du coup en
utilisant des éléments performants nous
pouvons faire tourner le moteur plus
vite donc rendre la voiture puissante et
nous pouvons également du coup augmenter
l'autonomie de la voiture en diminuant
donc l'énergie utilisée pour faire
tourner le moteur
et puis il n'ya pas terreur dans nos
aimant donc ils sont beaucoup moins
chers donc nous pourrions contribuer à
réduire le prix de la voiture électrique
est tous ensemble les chercheurs nous
essayons donc de rendre la voiture
électrique plus écologique
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]